[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we'll be discussing the top 10 worst
ways that Canon has been broken in The
Wizarding World of Harry Potter when an
author builds a fictional Universe over
the course of several decades there are
bound to be small contradictions here or
there but in the case of Harry Potter
and the ever expanding universe of the
Wizarding World there have been some
pretty big doozies when it comes to the
Cannon being not just broken but
completely shattered now I understand
that starting off a children's book
series in 1997 and continuing to build
that world for a more mature audience as
it was adapted for the Silver Screen
over the course of a couple decades
would be quite the undertaking and some
of the bits of cannon that have been
ignored throughout the years don't
really offend me all that much but there
are contradictions to some of the cannon
that just blatantly disregards the
original way that the story of Harry
Potter was told old and these are the
ones that I'll be focusing on in today's
video the following changes to Canon are
the top 10 that make many fans feel
quite infuriated myself included 10 the
late addition of abber for's son
throughout the original Harry Potter
series we learned very little about
Professor Albert Dumbledore's younger
brother abber for these sparse early
depictions of him paint the man as a
somewhat uneducated brute who had a
weird thing for goats this is pretty
well summed up by alus when he shared
the following in the Goblet of Fire my
own brother Abba forth was prosecuted
for practicing inappropriate charms on a
goat it was all over the papers but did
abber for hide no he did not he held his
head high and went about his business as
usual of course I'm not entirely sure he
can read so that may not have been
bravery from there little more is
revealed about four and his history
other than the fact that he was the
owner of the Hogs head in in hogsmeade
and part of the first order of the
Phoenix in the late
1970s and I suppose we also discover in
the Deathly Hallows that he was fiercely
protective of his younger sister Ariana
and later punched Albus in the nose
during her funeral all in all however we
never really learned anything concrete
about the wizard that is until the movie
release of Fantastic Beasts the secrets
of Dumbledore in this installment of the
films we discovered that AB forth SED a
long-lost son who is surprise credence
bebone the American obscurial from the
first few movies AKA Orelia stumbled or
now I'm not necessarily saying that this
breaks Cannon but at least to me it felt
really shoehorned into the narrative and
to be honest it just didn't fit with
what we had previously learned about
this Gruff Rough and Tumble character
the brother who maybe couldn't read and
had a weird thing for goats had a secret
tender love affair with a human woman I
don't know it just didn't fit with the
cannon of the Dumbledore family that had
long since bought into nine the
pronunciation of Voldemort for decades
fans of Harry Potter have been referring
to He Who Shall Not Be Named as
Voldemort with a hard te then in 2015
almost 20 years after the release of
Harry Potter and the philosopher stone
author JK rling shared that it was
actually meant to be pronounced with a
French accent in which the T should be
silent now if only we had the novels to
go by this would have been an acceptable
clarification but considering by 2015
all eight movies had also been released
in which Voldemort was pronounced
Voldemort I say what gives as Rowling
was involved in the making of the films
she would have had ample opportunity to
correct this
mispronunciation right so to casually
drop in years later that we've all been
saying Voldemort wrong for decades seems
to break what was believed to be Canon
for years eight Hogwarts Foreign
Exchange program in the gobbl of fire
foreign visiting schools outside of
Hogwarts are mentioned for the very
first time and not only they mentioned
they are actually Central to the very
plot of this installment in the series
as the two European institutions bobal
Academy of magic and The derring
Institute are together with Hogwarts the
three competing schools in the tri
wizard tournament and of course the go
of fire almost entirely revolves around
the events of this tournament and the
participating students from the three
schools what's more when the potential
champions from both bobor and durmstrang
first arrive at Hogwarts it is to much
gawking and Fanfare from the British
pupils almost as if the students of
Hogwarts had never met students from
other countries and yet in 2016 Whiting
world.com shared that Casto bruu the
Brazilian school for magic is well known
for its participation in an exchange
program with Hogwarts seven conflicting
ages and timelines now I understand that
when casting actors for a film you can't
always find someone to represent a
character perfectly and in the case of
the Harry Potter franchise The
filmmakers Who adap adapting the novels
to the Silver Screen had to make the
choice on whether or not to age up some
of the characters in order to cast Alan
Rickman as Professor s Snape they of
course decided to do so and while Alan
rickman's portrayal of Snape is quite
fantastic this Choice definitely broke
the Canon that had been established
around the timeline of Harry's parents
and witches and wizards who had attended
Hogwarts with them including Snape for
making seus older in the movies and in
the novels then had a domino effect on
the rest of the cast in the films as
they're all supposed to be the same age
as Snape as a result all of the movie
characters in that age group from Snape
to Lily and James Potter Sirus Black and
Remis Lupin were cast as older actors
than their book counterparts essentially
this group of witches and wizards were
made to be about 10 years older than
they had originally been written in
addition to this difference from
original Cannon there has also been some
contractions in terms of Bellatrix or
strange and snap's ages comparatively
there are a few instances where it's
meant mentioned that Bellatrix and Snape
ran in the same Circle while they
attended Hogwarts yet Bellatrix is meant
to be about a decade older than Snape
since Hogwarts offers 7 years of school
this would have made it impossible for
the two to have been part of the same
group while they were students as they
simply would not have been there at the
same time six Nini was once a human
maledictus never not once was it ever
alluded to throughout the Harry Potter
series that Lord Voldemort's pet serpent
Nini used to be a human witch for over
20 years we were led to believe that she
was no more than a snake a large and
vicious snake but a snake nonetheless
then in 2018 the crimes of grindal came
out and completely broke this cannon
apparently Nini had been interconnected
to Alba stumblor by way of his long lost
nephew Credence since at least the 1920s
and not as a serpent but as a young
witch who had been Afflicted with the
maledictus curse this previously unheard
of blood curse only affects females and
from what we see in the film it
seemingly allows the maledictus woman to
shape shift into a certain animal at
will for a time before eventually
transforming her into that Beast
permanently five a witch or wizard can
be their own Secret Keeper this next
example of Cannon being broken is in my
opinion a rather brutal one it's also
one that was broken relatively early on
in terms of the Harry Potter franchise
you see after learning about the
fidelia's charm in the prisoner of aaban
this brand of magic crops up a couple
times again in later installments with
Alber Dumbledore hiding Order of the
Phoenix headquarters at number 12 grimel
place and then Bill wizly hiding his
Home shell cottage for those who may
need a little reminder the Fidel's charm
as a spell that allows a person to
conceal a secret within a chosen Secret
Keeper Soul once the spell has been
performed Only The Secret Keeper can
share the secret and anyone else who may
stumble upon it accidentally would be
unable to actually see it for what it
was now here's where the cannon gets
broken Lily and James Potter wanted to
protect themselves and their baby Harry
when they learned that Voldemort was
after them in
1981 they decided to hide their location
with the fidelus charm they chose Peter
wormtail pettigru as their Secret Keeper
Petru then portray The Potters to the
dark lord and the rest is Wizarding
World History this is tragic in the way
that The Potters put their trust in the
wrong person but then as I mentioned in
the Order of the Phoenix Dumbledore
becomes his own secret keeper for the
location of number 12 of grimmel place
and in the Deathly Hallows bill is his
own secret keeper for Shell Cottage so
why oh why would Lil and James have
risked their lives and the life of their
infant by choosing someone else as their
Secret Keeper if they could have just
chosen themselves four manura
McGonagle's impossible appearance in
Fantastic Beasts Professor manura
mcgonagal is famous within the franchise
for her non nonsense loyal attitude
she's strong powerful and a real legend
among the Hogwarts professors
but as legendary as she is she's not
capable of being somewhere before she's
even been born right well in both
fantastic Beast movies the crimes of
grindal and the secrets of Dumbledore a
young Professor by the name of manura
mcgonagal shows up in a couple scenes at
Hogwarts and hogsmeade why is this a
problem you may be asking because these
movies take place in 1927 and 1937
respectively and the professor mcgonagal
that we know In Love from Harry's days
as a student at Hogwarts she wasn't born
until
1935 which means that in the first
fantastic Beast film that she shows up
in Canon indicates that she would not
have been alive yet and in the second
she would have only been 2 years old
three the capabilities of a Time Turner
ah the time Turner what a nightmare to
entangle this simple device has caused
so many fans headache after headache
some of these headaches were temporarily
cured with if I'm being honest pretty
lazy explanations however at least these
explanations accounted for some
potentially serious plot holes but then
Harry Potter and the cursed child
basically went back on everything we'd
been told and ruined everything allow me
to explain when the concept of the time
Turner first showed up in the prison of
aaban it brought up many questions like
if time travel is possible why couldn't
Harry just go back in time and save his
parents from baldemort to this and other
questions we were given the answer that
the past cannot be altered and what's
done is done this closed the loop on any
potential alternate timelines time
Turners also could only travel back a
few hours at a time as anyone who
engaged in time travel was subject to
the effect of Aging equaling the amount
of time they traveled this again helped
fans understand why Harry couldn't or
shouldn't go back 10 years as he would
have lost over a decade of his life and
he then wouldn't have even been able to
do anything differently once he got
there finally in a somewhat
anticlimactic fashion all the time
Turners that were owned by the British
Ministry magic were said to have been
destroyed during a fight in the
department of mysteries but in a
complete contradiction to basically all
of that in the cursed child the
characters go back in time far further
than a day with a Time Turner that they
seem to have somehow magically recovered
in order to change the past I don't know
about you but I feel a migraine coming
on two the Muckle camera that worked at
Hogwarts here's a cannon break that
bothers a number of fans despite it
being rather benign the presence of
Colin ky's camera and its ability to
function at Hogwart School of Witchcraft
and Wizardry in the Chamber of Secrets
we meet Harry Potter Super Fan Colin
creevy a firste student at Hogwarts who
was rather interested in all things
Harry this in itself is not the problem
the problem in regards to Canon is the
fact that Colin is constantly carrying
around and using a somewhat
old-fashioned muggle camera and as we've
been told muggle Electronics do not work
at Hogwart School otherwise wouldn't
there have been many other gadgets and
pieces of tech popping up at the school
throughout the series this one actually
might have an answer we see Colin's
using an old school film camera and if
the camera is old enough I.E pre-60s
then it's likely that it doesn't use any
electricity one Bellatrix and
Voldemort's baby girl coming in at the
top of today's list as the worst way
that Harry Potter Cannon has been broken
is one example that has become rather
Infamous within the fan base and that is
the fact that Bellatrix the strange in
Voldemort apparently had a baby together
in the cursed child it is revealed that
Bellatrix gave birth to a baby girl
named delini whose father was none other
than the dark lord himself now this
makes little sense when put into context
with the original series first of all
there is no indication that Voldemort
and Bellatrix had an intimate
relationship was she obsessed with him
sure did Helena Bolam cart's
representation of Bellatrix
hypersexualize The Witch's character
certainly but did these two have carnal
relations uh no Voldemort does not seem
even slightly interested in Bellatrix in
this way throughout either the novels or
films not to mention that he was so
focused on becoming Immortal and taking
down Harry that it seems rather unlikely
that he would have even found the time
for this type of distraction but for
argument sake let's say that he did
enjoy the company of Bellatrix what
about his weird new body I mean it was
created by wormtail in a cauldron and he
ended up having a face that resembled a
snake could he really have been up for
it then of course there's a timeline of
it now the act of conceiving delini is
not the issue I suppose Voldemort and
Bellatrix could have sneakily done that
at any time
the problem is more about pinpointing
when Bellatrix would have been pregnant
and given birth considering that in
order for the timeline to match up to
Del's age in the cursed child Bellatrix
would have had to give birth sometime
during the events of the Deathly Hallows
I find it incredibly hard to believe
that this is what happened for example
Bellatrix is in tiptop fighting form
when the trio run into her at Malfoy
Manor and she tortures herione and kills
Dobby she's clearly not pregnant in this
scene and that's one hell of a recovery
if she had just had the baby also
speaking of the baby if Bellatrix was no
longer pregnant at that point where in
Merlin's beard was delini and with that
we've come to the end of another video
what did you think do you have any other
terrible ways that Harry Potter Cannon
has been broken do you agree with my
picks for the top 10 worst ones please
share your thoughts in the comments
below and as always if you enjoyed this
video don't forget to like it and
subscribe to the channel also be sure to
check out the content on Spotify as well
as extra content on my second Channel
how report a theory extra until next
time remember it does not do to dwell on
dreams and forget to
[Music]
live